this is the first time Seoul Korea if he
loses just like it's over I've seen
David be fair to my company he's
involved in it's dark it's gloomy yet it
is dark it's dark gloomy and [ __ ]
but you know what it works I ain't
pulling intermedium in a Rolls Royce and
I've got like ten people waiting for me
in the gym wanted to stroke me back one
second let me knots want to do me food
wanted to massage me bollocks amigo
another wants her to do me I don't have
all the same up at the gym and it's just
me undies
last time around you know I had the
wrong mindset I wasn't in the right
mental state I wasn't in the right
physical state I went in there like a
thug like a like a bully who believed
they're just bigger and stronger than
someone said he's been squashing and
that for me
you know is there's a fundamental no no
boxing this couple be 14 weeks long yeah
I've been common and staying in that
shipping of an old shell for there for
11 weeks now that starts pardon a lot
earlier than this guy a lot earlier than
this compass don't a lot lot more around
so you know I'm not sure out on anyone
but well over a hundred rounds let's not
forget it these guys come in and I'm a
name you know these these fellas would
love nothing more than to coming in and
render me unconscious and go out and
tell the mates I'll go out and tell the
world I've just knocked out one of the
best fighters in the world in this
division so that's what I'm not willing
to every time every time these guys turn
on but tend not to face Tony value WBC's
world champion the guy who's wanted all
British Commonwealth European world
champion the guy who's chopped bills on
box-office if they can cheer me in here
that's a huge thing for their league
onwards for me it's just another spark
fighters need the occasional kick up the
arse to keep him keep him on the right
track and I believe in ourselves is that
guy to keep him mentally on track he
studies every single thing and he
understands what I can do what I can't
do I'm good at and what I'm very
vulnerable to and he's a type of guy to
make sure that whatever I am vulnerable
to that he tries to patch up and the
things that I'm good at he tries to sort
of make flourish he tries to really sort
of fine-tune my attributes you know
highlight match abuse and bring them to
the forefront
[Music]
not just to be them this whole career I
know everything about his career I have
always tell you things about his clear
that he may not even be able to tell you
himself I just I know what he's gonna do
I know when he switches and I when he
moves left and when he moves right and
no when he backs up what he's looking
for and it showed in the first fight
that's why I made them miss and look
stupid if I make one wrong calculation
or I make a move at the wrong time that
can go wrong like I said awakened
hundreds of a second so just one little
slips of the right at the wrong time
means the right hand the chin on the
chin
instead of hitting you on the gloss and
that can be the difference in a fight
like this I've gone back to my haymaker
gym in box'll next door to the Park
Plaza in London and I've won all my
flights when I've been based here and
this time around I wanted to do it you
know how always diving it up I brought
back onto the team Rubin tabara is my
strength conditioning coach we've really
ramped that up now who's really fired up
some stuff in me that had been dormant
for way too many years
[Music]
[Applause]
the first time in his whole career he's
had his career on the line in the fight
because there's always been excuses for
David the loss to call Thompson it's
it's bouncing an experience you know he
just took to fight too soon in his
career the Fighting's wladimir klitschko
I've got a sore top he loses to me
it's all me Achilles when you've got a
number the only thing he was hitting in
the first two rounds was fresher and
then when he even did hit me after then
first two rounds of past it had no
effect so you know it is what it is this
is the first time his whole key if he
loses this like it's all
[Music]
they say if you don't use it you lose it
and I'd lost basically all of my
athleticism all of my speed all my
timing all of what makes the haymaker
the haymaker and I'm proud to tell you
all he's back and you'll see it in full
effect on May 5th and Mayfest I close
the curtain on one of the greatest clues
awaits the world has seen since around
the Holyfield